so i have three different functions here
i know they're all called f but let's
just assume they are different functions
and for each of these i want to do three
things i want to find the zeros
and so the zeros are the input values
that make the value of the function
equal to zero so here would be the t
values that make f of t equals zero here
would be the x values that make the
function equal zero so i want to find
the zeros
i also want to find the coordinates of
the vertex
and finally i want to find the equation
of the line of symmetry
line of symmetry and in particular to
make it a little bit more specific the
vertical line of symmetry which will
actually be the only line of symmetry
for for these three so pause the video
and see if you can figure out the zeros
the vertex and the line of symmetry
and i'm assuming you just did that and
now i'm going to attempt to do it at any
point you get inspired
pause the video again and keep on
working on it the best way to learn this
stuff is to do it yourself so let's see
so let's first find the zeros so to find
the zeros we can set t minus five
squared minus nine equal to zero
so we could say
t
for what t's does t minus five squared
minus nine
equals 0.
let's see to solve this we could add 9
to both sides and so we could say if we
add 9 to both sides the left hand side
is just t minus 5
squared the right hand side is going to
be 9.
and so if t minus 5 squared is 9 that
means that t minus 5
could be equal to the positive square
root of 9 or
t minus 5 could equal the negative
square root of 9.
and to solve for t we could add 5 to
both sides so we get t is equal to 8
or t is equal to if we add 5 to both
sides here t is equal to 2. and just
like that we have found the zeros for
this function because if t is equal to 8
or 2 the function is going to be 0. f of
8 is 0 and f of an f of 2 is going to be
0.
now let's find the vertex the
coordinates of the vertex
the coordinates of the vertex
so the x-coordinate of the vertex or
sorry i should say the t-coordinate of
the vertex since the input variable here
is t
the t-coordinate of the vertex is going
to be halfway in between the zeros it's
going to be halfway in between where the
where the the parabola in this case is
going to intersect the x-axis or the
t-axis i keep saying x-axis the t-axis
for this case so halfway between 8 and 2
well it's going to be the average of
them 8 plus 2 over 2 that's 10 over 2
that's 5.
so the t coordinate is 5 and 5 is 3 away
from 8 and 3 away from 2
and when t is equal to 5 what is f of t
or what is f of 5 well when t is equal
to 5 5 minus 5 squared is just 0 and
then f of so f of 5 is just going to be
negative 9.
and this form of a function this is
actually called vertex form because it's
very easy to pick out the vertex it's
very easy to realize like okay look for
this particular one we're going to hit a
minimum point when this part of the
expression is equal to zero
because this thing at the lowest value
it can take on is zero because you're
squaring it it can never take on a
negative value and it takes on zero when
t is equal to five and if that's if this
part is zero then the f of five is going
to be negative nine so just like that we
have established the vertex
now we actually have a lot of
information if we wanted to draw it so
if we want to draw this function i'll
just do a very quick sketch of it
whoops
so very quick sketch of it
so that is our t-axis not our x-axis
after i keep reminding myself
and
that is my
let's call that my y-axis and we're
going to graph y is equal to f of t
well we know the vertex is at the point
5 comma negative 9. so this is
t is equal to 5
and y is equal to negative 9.
so that's the vertex
right over there and then we know we
have zeros at t equals eight and t
equals two so t equals eight and t
equals two
let me make that a little bit and t
equals two those are the two zeros so 8
and 2 and so just like that we can graph
f of t or we can graph y is equal to f
of t
so y is equal to f of t is going to look
something like
something like let me draw something
like
that that's the graph
of y is equal to f of t now the last
thing that i said is the line of
symmetry well the line of symmetry is
going to be
the vertical line that goes through the
vertex
so the equation of that line of symmetry
is going to be t is equal to 5.
and it's really just the t coordinate of
the vertex
that defines the line of symmetry let's
do the other two right over here
so what are the zeros
well if you set this equal to zero if we
say x plus two
times x plus four
is equal to zero well that's going to
happen if
x plus 2 is equal to 0 or
x plus 4 is equal to 0 this is going to
happen if we subtract 2 from both sides
when x is negative 2 and if we subtract
4 from both sides or when x is equal to
negative 4.
as we said the vertex
the x coordinate of the vertex is going
to be halfway in between these so it's
going to be negative 2
plus negative 4 over 2 so that would be
negative 6 over two which is just
negative three
and when x is negative three
f of x is going to be let's see it's
going to be negative one
times
times one right negative 3 negative 3
plus 2 is negative 1
negative and so times 1. so it's just
going to be negative 1.
there you have it and the line of
symmetry is going to be the vertical
line x is equal to negative 3. and once
again we can we can graph that really
fast
so let me
this is my
y-axis see everything is happening
for negative x's so i'll
draw it a little bit more skewed this
way
this is my x-axis and we see that we
have zeros at x equals negative two and
x is equal to negative four
so negative one
two three
four so we have zeros
we have zeros
there
oh negative two let me be careful
negative two
and negative four and the vertex is at
negative 3 comma negative 1. so negative
3 comma negative 1.
make sure we see that so this is
negative 1 right over here
negative 1 this is negative 2 this is
negative 4. and so we can sketch out
sketch out what the graph of y is equal
to f of x is going to look like it's
going to look something
something like that
that is y is equal to f of x
let's do one more hopefully we're
getting the hang of this
so here to solve x squared plus 6 x plus
8 is equal to 0 it will be useful to
factor this
and so this can be written as and if you
have trouble doing this i encourage you
to watch videos on factoring polynomials
what adds up to six and when you take
their product is eight well four and two
four plus two is six and four times two
is eight
so
is equal to zero
and then this is actually the exact same
thing as what we have in blue right over
here these are actually the exact same
function they're just written in
different forms and so the solutions are
going to be the exact solutions that we
just saw right over here and the graph
is going to be the same thing that we
have right over there so same vertex
same line of symmetry same zeros this
these functions were just written in
different ways